con serenidad del 3 virginia martínez
alista su restaurante en el distrito
turístico de barranco en lima que hoy
atiende al 30 por ciento de su capacidad
la crisis económica por la pandemia del
coi 19 lo dejó endeudado y con múltiples
pérdidas
estaba muy en deudas pero lo estamos
asumiendo como
y bueno la vida es así hoy en día toca
vivir
estamos viviendo con lo que tendremos no
sabe por quién votar el próximo 11 de
abril y se siente resignado estamos de
alguna manera formateado a escuchar
[Música]
que no sabemos sean aplicar
en el distrito popular el callado de la
capital peruana el doctor luís alberto
núñez es cirujano en un hospital público
él ha sido testigo del desinterés de los
gobiernos por mejorar la salud en el
país se siente desilusionado porque
ningún candidato tiene previsto aumentar
la inversión en el sector a pesar de las
deficiencias que la pandemia reveló y
esta decepción no solamente viene porque
la desinformación que existe no
solamente en los médicos sino también en
toda la población no hay mucho hay mucha
defraudación de cuatro los candidatos no
los partidos también se han venido abajo
agüita urbina es profesora de inglés
desarrolla sus clases por una plataforma
[Música]
en perú la mayoría de escuelas siguen
atendiendo a los estudiantes de manera
virtual sin que haya siempre los
recursos necesarios en las familias
dejando a muchos niños en el abandono
escolar que forma parte de los
ejercicios ya que no sé por qué
candidato o votar hay tantos candidatos
que realmente para uno le es imposible
indagar en cada candidato y también
sobre las propuestas que dan ninguna se
enfoca en lo que es la educación más de
25 millones de peruanos acudirán a las
ánforas en el momento más crítico de la
pandemia y después de un año marcado por
muchos escándalos políticos unas
circunstancias que podrían debilitar aún
más estas elecciones presidenciales